so welcome to council of geeks I'm
joined tonight by Paul scoubidou and
Brian daily and tonight we are going to
be talking about what we feel is a
notable underrated comic book movie
we've all got our picks and he
volunteers to go first
I'll dive in and so I feel like this
one's particularly timely because the
batfleck is going to be dropping on us
fairly soon and so I wanted to return to
daredevil admittedly has problems and I
think the majority of those problems lie
in the action sequences they are hard to
follow you can't really tell what's
going on I think it's mostly editing I
think you know they went in for the
rapid cut thing there's a lot that the
film gets right and I think that one of
the things that I really enjoyed about
that movie was the visualization of what
Matt Murdock's power look like and that
the first time we see it it's really
cool and we kind of get like he this is
how he sees and how he's so effective
and what this power has sort of become
because I thought that was a great
moment in the movie I really thought
that actually Ben Affleck did a pretty
good job with the conflict that Matt
Murdock struggles with the conflict
between his worlds of being this man of
the law right fighting the singalong and
having this inherently illegal activity
that he's being a part of I thought that
been a fight actually handled that
pretty well have you seen the directors
cook that sort of extended my act they
haven't I found myself more interested
in that kind of everyday Half legal
procedural and half just the the
detective work of his character by night
the kind of general miss I'd like that a
little bit more than the overload of
other villains and characters with
Elektra and bullseye I don't care about
either of them well this was one that I
considered being my one to do because I
do that I don't I do think it's
underrated but I think I think
ultimately the film's biggest sin is
that it tries to do too much they've got
they have to cover in some way his
origin
they do Elektra and bullseye and kingpin
and it's it's like it's too much they
tried to cram too much into one movie
which while a problem is the mistake
that people who care about the material
made right and for me what I'm kind of
really looking at is Ben's performance
in the film and how he owned the
character and I think you know I think
he really went into a lot of heart and I
think he really did try to convey the
character of as Matt Murdock as
carefully as he could and and I'm
clinging to this because I really need
that to be true in Man of Steel well and
so I heard that I don't think Ben
Affleck was the problem with daredevil
no and I don't think he'll be the
problem with Superman vs Batman Donna
dawn of the rising no I think that's a
soul I think I think you know we'll find
things too in all cases things to maybe
rag on on these but you know in most
cases there's a reason they were
somewhat underappreciated but you know
so for for my pick yeah it's it's
Punisher war zone and I actually could
have gone with either of the two new or
Punisher movies because I actually feel
they're both underrated the reason I'm
opting to talk about war zone is I
understand why people didn't like the
Thomas Jane Punisher because they felt
the character was softened and he wasn't
harsh enough and I understand the
criticism I don't understand what
people's problem with war zone is
because they were given exactly the
character that everyone said they wanted
in the first movie didn't get and I
think that movie captures so amazingly
the tone of the best kind of recent
Punisher comic books which is harsh
gritty and darkly funny this is the the
Garth Ennis Punisher and it's that very
purely put up on screen now I understand
why mainstream people didn't go for it
because it was so harsh that it was too
hard formation but fans like comic book
lovers crapped all over this movie and I
I
we'll never understand why because I
think it captures everything that they
say they love about the comic and put it
on the screen and nobody went for it
this is kind of an issue that I have and
I read the Garth Ennis run on the comics
and I enjoyed it but for the most part I
found that the Punisher in that story
isn't really a character he doesn't have
in the park
he's a very flat character who's almost
a force of nature in a sense who's just
retribution
he's just punishment personified does
that translate into the film you find a
character in there you do find a
character in that but you can have a
character without having a character arc
and another recent example that I would
cite as that as a movie that did that
well was Dredd which was a movie that is
actually very much in the same vein and
toe as Punisher war zone and hat Wow not
necessary financially accessible
everyone I know who has seen Dredd has
loved it and the fans have embraced it
and again just makes me go why didn't
you also go for this because there are
characters what actually the character
hasn't Kirk oddly enough is jigsaw I
think the property is inherently tainted
because there have been very poorly
received Punishers and several of them
at this point yeah I think that there's
this almost like gag reflex that server
comes with I think people are prejudging
the film before they get to it I'll just
cop dad I just love Ray Stevenson yeah I
would like to see him in everything
every movie ever and I would be very
happy for that so I'm biased on that
note I'll grant I think the next time we
see Punisher we'll be in a Netflix
series I'm either as a guest star in the
defenders or is it like a secret Easter
egg in daredevil or something like that
or after if these are successful they
might give him his own the movie that I
had on mine was Superman Returns and I
think I think for a lot of people it did
it failed to meet their expectations
they were they I think it came out right
after Batman Begins and they were hoping
that this would reenergize that property
the same way that Batman Begins did and
it didn't for a number of reasons I
think first and foremost is that Bryan
Singer made a love letter to the Richard
Donner film oh yeah it has more omage
--is to those films than actual original
ideas which kills it and i think that is
a really serious problem however there
were three major things that I enjoyed
about this movie especially when I would
compare it to something like Man of
Steel which just came out which is what
I heard a lot of people saying they
didn't like Man of Steel but they would
rather watch that than Superman Returns
and I said a thousand times no I
disagree with that
so the primarily the things that I find
redeeming about Superman rips the things
that I've find enjoyable if I watched it
again the performances by Brandon Ralph
and Kevin Spacey Oh God Brandon Ralph
has moments where he it seems like he's
channeling Christie Christopher Reeves
but he never feels like he's doing an
impression and I think Kevin Spacey's as
Lex Luthor for a modern depiction of Lex
Luthor the kind of corporate bigwig Lex
Luthor I think Kevin Spacey captures
that perfectly there are two standout
action sequences obviously the one where
Superman is saving the plane from
falling after the EMP and he has to
dislodge it from this spatial and we see
him saving the day and it is thrilling
it's action-packed you see him in all
his glory later on towards the end of
the film metropolis the city itself is
in danger he catches people who are
falling he catches like signs and
billboards before they cross people he
stops a gas main explosion before it
incinerates an entire city block and
watching Man of Steel Superman should
have done something about that there
were problems there weren't enough good
ideas in Superman Returns and they did
there are times when it's boring which a
Superman movie should never be boring
but there are also times when I was like
that feels like Superman and I never got
that from Man of Steel the main thing is
that they it needed editing because a
lot of people complained that it wasn't
an enough action but it wasn't that I
needed more action scenes injected to it
it needed more the dead time Batol
them removed because I think in trying
to capture those richard donner movies
Bryan Singer didn't always take into
account what the limitations of the time
work because there is a fair amount of
downtime especially in the original
Superman culture but part of the reason
there was so much downtime is they
couldn't afford and did not have the
means to do to have him flying for the
entire movement right you've got the
means to do that now I mean don't go
don't go man of steel level crazy with
it but you don't have those limitations
you are not obligated to fill time I
have to ask them if but for Man of Steel
right do you think your opinion of this
film would be as positive I would still
see the same problems I saw and I would
still see the same gems that I've seen
it because I left the theater with a
mostly positive feeling after I saw
Superman Returns even if I hadn't seen
Man of Steel I would still feel that
this was an underrated or at least a
movie with some redemptive quality yes I
mean if anything maybe Man of Steel
brought it into sharper clarity perhaps
here's an odd thing though as much as as
I agree with you I'm pretty much
everything you've said I am glad that it
didn't get a sequel be cut for one
specific reason because of super kid
well the seeds then they were laying
four things Avenues I didn't want to go
right examine it now maybe that said in
that movie I actually really liked it I
really loved that moment where the piano
just gets thrown across as you look over
and there's the kid you go oh crap and
it just dawns on you what that means
unfortunately where they would have had
to go if they ever got a second movie I
I didn't want to yeah I don't want to
see that either oh so there you have it
there's our three picks for what we
consider our some underrated superhero
gem so we've got Superman Returns you've
got daredevil we've got Punisher warzone
there are plenty of other ones out there
with better qualities than people give
them credit for so what is your personal
favorite underrated comic book movie
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and maybe we'll talk about
it but until next time this council is a
jerk oh I changed my pick
how are the Duncan